[Music]
honestly it's kind of surreal you guys i
i
can you believe it's been 20 years since
the first x-men maybe 20 years
not judging by halle oh you're not so
bad yourself professor
and family's making me think that i
should have dressed up a little bit more
hmm
knock knock whoa so many stars
is that one was that ian mckellen ryan
the cast and i were all just reminiscing
about the movie that we're all in
together
i hear you you know i love that that
movie
i hope it's okay if i join i figured we
were all in
x-men together x-men origins yeah
always good seeing you ryan i actually
invited a few others hey guys hey
everyone
so many timelines it's like a recap of
knott's landing two professors one cup
what's happening it's just like the
x-men movies you know it doesn't matter
oh sorry i actually thought this was the
game of thrones reunion
you know uh tyrion lannister was in an
x-men film okay
bye i actually have a james bond reunion
soon
oh god me too split reunion star trek
i love you patrick stewart bye everyone
that fell apart quickly this is just you
and me logan
i guess so you know uh you know what
that
makes this a reunion for x-men origins
reunite